colin bank congratulations you guys are
moving forward into round three only the
man next to you stands between you the
title of fortune fire champion and that
coveted check for ten thousand dollars
in round three we're gonna send you guys
back home to recreate an iconic weapon
from history that weapon is
the vajramushti wow
originating in india the vachamushti is
an edge knuckle duster the unique design
features sharpened blades on every side
of the handle making it a specialty
weapon only wielded by well-trained
indian warriors the sharp edges on all
sides provided the user with a wide
range of lethal attacks from deadly
stabs and slashes to devastating punches
a traditional indian martial art where
the weapon is tied to the fists of
wrestlers has lineage dating back to the
middle ages and is still practiced today
by professional wrestlers in india using
non-lethal knuckle dusters
i don't even i don't even know what to
say the closest thing i've seen to that
is probably a pair of brass knuckles
we're gonna send you guys home for four
days and when you guys come back i wanna
see two blades worth at least ten
thousand dollar piece so do your
absolute best work and good luck we'll
see you in four days awesome good luck
man good luck
[Music]
i feel good to be back home here in
bellows falls vermont and we're going to
make the bajra mushti i've never made a
bajramushti or anything close to him so
i decided to use 1084 carbon steel
because it's something i'm more familiar
with
i think the most difficult part of the
challenge will be making the handle
something that i'm definitely going to
have to pay a lot of attention to
[Music]
the two smaller blades are basically the
same one's a little longer than the
other you know and then the other blades
it's a big rectangle
five hours into it i feel pretty good
uh one more soap in the forge then i'll
quench them
i got all the forging out of the way so
i'm feeling good
end of day one i'm really glad i got the
heat treat done
looks good
day two i'm a little tired this morning
but i feel great ready to get this show
on the road i decide that i'm gonna go
with a torch heat treatment because the
handle doesn't need to be hard i just
need the blades hard and the knuckle
blade heart
if i did one and i'm scared i'm gonna
crack it in half because right after the
quench it is brittle so any little shock
or hit could cause catastrophic cracking
luckily i don't see any cracks
so i think the quench went well
that's gonna have to do
[Music]
it's beginning of day two and i can't
wait to get started for the handle i'm
gonna go with copper it's moving a lot
better than i thought it was going to
i want to pay really close attention to
detail i want to make a 10 000 knife
today i'm able to remove three pounds
off a five pound chunk of copper and
not got a nice workable piece tomorrow
i'd like to get the handle all finished
up and the blades fit it on
that's basically it
it's day four ready to get this thing
done
so i just got done doing the profiling
on my baja mushti
feels pretty good i'm gonna start doing
fit up on the handle
i'm feeling great
at the end of the day i used every
minute that i had
there's definitely some finishing
touches that i didn't get to that i wish
i had
mainly the handle
i'm hoping that there's not you know
major hot spots around the knuckles or
anything like that it can look like
crap but as long as it feels comfortable
in your hand you know that's fine i feel
good i mean
i definitely did the best that i could
bladesmiths welcome to the kill test to
find out what kind of lethal damage your
weapon will do i will take your weapon
to deliver multiple lethal blows on this
ballistics dummy
kyle you're up first you ready oh yeah
wow
all right kyle let's talk about your
weapon here i was worried about the
finger welts that you had there that
they would be an issue especially when
i'm punching no issues there
i like the fact that as it gets slippery
it gave me a very good grip overall it
is a beautiful piece and your weapon
will kill oh yeah
all right ben your turn sir are you
ready i'm ready let's do this
[Music]
all right ben let's talk about your
weapon here
the edges are very sharp
but there are some sharp edges that you
have in here every movement started to
give me a little bruise and cut off some
skin right there
but in terms of
what this weapon will do
it will kill
thanks doug my hand
all right blade smith welcome to the
strength test
to test the strength and durability of
your vajra mushties as well as their
overall construction i'll be stabbing
and punching into this sheet metal and
chain kyle you're up first you ready for
this yep
[Music]
all right kyle in this strength test
your two long blades held up great the
center blade here took some chipping on
that chain i'm looking at the grain in
there and it's it's pretty big uh i
would have liked to have seen that
refined but in general these two blades
held up well nice job awesome thanks ben
all right ben you're up you ready for
this sure am
[Music]
[Music]
all right ben well the first thing i
feel when i pick this weapon up is its
sheer mass i mean it's a heavy heavy
weapon that did you some justice in the
strength test the only thing i could see
is a little bit of glinting on the lower
blade but the middle blade
it took a pretty major deflection right
here
it kind of cracked one more little
little hit here and that would just come
off the main thing working against you
on this blade is
the rough inner surface
i couldn't really find a real
comfortable way of getting this finger
out of harm's way but after the strength
test is all in one piece
nice job thank you
all right bladesmiths we know your
weapons can feel and we know they are
strong now it's time to find out just
how sharp they are to find out it'll
take your weapons and deliver some stabs
and slices on these spice bags
call you up first you ready for this yup
let's do this
[Music]
all right let's talk about your weapon
it is comfortable it's a good fit on my
hand it's got a pointy enough tip over
there but with that one piece where
you're missing some edges it was more of
a jagged cut when it came to stabbing
and slashing on both weapons on each end
it'll cut good job thank you doug
bend your turns are you ready ready
let's go let's do it
all right ben talk about your weapon
the weight that you have here back up
the cut because you have very sharp
edges and the cuts are very deep but my
hand when i'm making impact still rubs
on the inside of your handle but other
than that sir your beast
it will cut thanks doug
all right guys you guys both came
through with unbelievable pieces of work
verging on art and they performed almost
equally on all the tests unfortunately
we can only send one of you guys home
with the title of fortune fire champion
and a check for ten thousand dollars and
our champion today is
[Music]
kyle congratulations ben unfortunately
you're not walking home to champion
today doug's going to tell you why ben i
commend you on building a very unique
weapon but only your handle affected
both of us when we were testing it for
that reason we're sending you home
totally understand
ben you obviously showed you have what
it takes to be in the forge and to
compete with some of the best but
unfortunately the time has come and i
have to ask you to leave the fourth
floor
thank you guys
this was awesome for sure kyle amazing
job honestly i feel great i mean it was
an amazing experience i'm super happy
for kyle i had a feeling that handel was
gonna get me but i busted my butt and
honestly did the best that i could so i
don't have any regrets
well kyle congratulations you'll be
leaving here with the title forging fire
champion and a check for ten thousand
dollars congratulations thank you my
wife's gonna be super pumped when i tell
her that i'm the next fortune fire
champion
what are you gonna do with that cash man
my wife and i probably gonna use it for
a down payment on a house that's
absolutely fantastic
18 months ago i would have never
imagined being here today hell yeah i'm
forgetting fire champion
[Music]
you